speaking of joe biden joe biden has
again made the correct decision when it
comes to yet another request from former
president donald trump to shield the
white house visitor logs from the days
right around the january 6 2021 trump
riots trump wants those to be hidden joe
biden has said no reuters report biden
gives the january 6th panel access to
trump's white house visitor logs
president joe biden has rejected former
president donald trump's executive
privilege claims and ordered white house
visitor logs to be released to the panel
investigating the deadly january 6 2021
attack according to a letter released on
wednesday in a letter to the national
archives biden's white house counsel
granted congressional investigators
access to the data given the urgency of
their work probing trump supporters
violent siege of the capital and ordered
the agency to turn over the logs within
15 days 15 days
the president has determined meaning joe
biden the president has determined that
an assertion of executive privilege is
not in the best interests of the united
states and therefore is not justified as
to these records and portions of records
that's biden's council council dana
remus
importantly
biden last year also rejected trump's
bid to block the u.s house of
representatives committee
january 6 committee from accessing
batches of documents from the former
president's time at the white house the
associated press similarly reporting
biden orders release of trump white
house logs to congress the committee has
sought a trove of data from the national
archives including presidential records
that trump fought to keep private the
records being released to congress are
visitor logs showing appointment
information for individuals allowed to
enter the white house on the day of the
insurrection now i have a couple
thoughts on this first of all as i've
said before just think about it
just apply your own sense of reason to
this
is this the behavior of someone with
nothing to hide and the answer is of
course no
of course no
the the second part of this is you know
who visits the white house who visits a
president at the president at the white
house
is just like base level public
information and so aside from whether
generally speaking
this is the behavior of someone with
nothing to hide or of someone with a
guilty conscience
this is like
basic level information that when you
promise to have the most transparent
administration in history as donald
trump did
trump ran on obama has not been
transparent i will be transparent and
then you try to shield just white house
visitor logs this is a basic element of
transparency
but there's another issue which is
i would make a bet
that there are many visitors to the
white house whose names were never put
into the logs in the first place it
would be shocking to me
if the white house logs that they are
trying to shield
are even complete in terms of
representing everybody that visited
donald trump at the white house and then
again remember last week we learned
about trump power flushing documents and
clogging the toilet
um
how do we know that there aren't some of
these that have been flushed or
attempted to be flushed and then fished
out of the toilet by trump's staff
none of it makes sense and if you think
back to 2016 you'll remember donald
trump saying about hillary clinton
people who have nothing to hide don't
destroy evidence to keep it from being
publicly archived as required under
federal law that's what trump said about
hillary he said hillary's behavior with
documents is disqualifying to her as
president
look at what trump has done
ripping up documents incinerating
documents
flushing documents
begging joe biden to hide documents but
he said hillary is the one that we can't
trust of course it doesn't make any
sense so
this is about the release of documents
to the january 6th committee not to the
public whether those documents will be
made public by being leaked or who knows
if and when they are given to the
january 6 committee we just don't know
yet but this is the correct decision and
this is further
uh um a further indication that this is
a guy with a guilty conscience who
doesn't want us to know
who visited the white house on that day
now
what might be if if the logs are
complete
what might they reveal they might reveal
that members of right-wing militia
groups visited the white house
they might reveal
that uh individual members of congress
who were in contact with rioters also
visited the white house we just don't
know we don't know and that's why the
records need to be released we'll have
more on this on our instagram find us on
instagram at david pakman show and we'll
be back right after this
one of our sponsors is all form hands
down the easiest way to custom build
your own sofa you choose the premium
fabric you want you choose the sofa size
shape color even the color of the legs
you can customize every aspect of your
new sofa to make sure it's the perfect
fit for your home i got my first
all-form sofa a year ago i just got a
second one which is really exciting
these really are the sofas i would have
bought for my home even if all form was
not a sponsor you really can't beat the
quality the modern minimal design the
sofas are spill stain and scratch proof
you can buy one piece and start with
that and then buy more seats and
accessories to add on later shipping is
fast and free you get a hundred days to
decide if you want to keep the sofa it
comes with a forever warranty and you'll
get 20 percent off when you go to all
form dot com slash pacman the link is
right underneath this video